hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast profiling yourself
surface of cancer cell lines for
biomarker drugs target discovery using
MS based proteomics presented by Joseph
plunder in the senior scientist cancer
research technology program Frederick
National Laboratory for cancer research
I am Christina mahalik of libraries and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we aren't the lightest to bring you this
educational web seminar percentage
buying libraries libraries is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this isn't is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this presentation is
educational and those offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left of the corner
and follow the process to obtain your
credit please join me in welcoming dr.
blonder I will now turn the presentation
over to him dr. blonder before is yours
Thank You Kristina for the introduction
so in this presentation I will shortly
explain what mass spectrometry based
proteomics is I will talk about
molecular profiling profiling of
biological specimens and focus on
membrane is all surface proteins after
that we will be talking about cancer
biomarker and drug discovery and show
through the couple of application and
finish up with conclusions and further
directions liquid chromatography tandem
mass spectrometry also knows in shotgun
proteomics is analytical tool where
proteins are digested into the diptych
baptised with trypsin and analyzed using
reverse phase chromatography followed by
processing and unification of proteins
mass spectrometry based proteomics has
certain challenges like any omics
technologies however ours are the major
issue with the proteomics is that we
don't have a luxury genomics or ivory
proteins so the dynamic range and
abundant proteins are an issue which
should be addressed properly so the
dynamic range issue is very important
because in for example in a plasma or
serum the concentration range dynamic
range of protein concentration is about
10 to 11 while current mass spectrometry
spectrometers have dynamic range of
maybe 6 to 7 so that gap should be
properly addressed because most probably
the proteins that we are looking for are
not housekeeping proteins our biomarker
and drug targets the child's lower
abundance therefore there are different
ways how to address the dynamic range in
in mass spectrometry based proteomics
most the most common way of doing it is
to do sub cellular fractionation
in terms of enriching for kind of like a
plasma membrane mitochondria nuclei if
you have focus on that so that the the
rest of the subcellular proteome is
eliminated or use different kind of
separation techniques like
electrophoresis SDS page 2d page
capillary electrophoresis or use
different kind of fractionation
techniques like reverse phase or ion
exchange a strong cation exchange also
an old way was also the MS based
fractionation that we are looking into
the M over Z fractionation focusing of
the smaller
M over the range to generate the the
depth any of these is good but it is
definitely important to figure out and
find out which one of those is the best
to use given the analytical or presume
ik sample we are looking into in our
laboratory we use strong cation exchange
fractionation which is similar to much
pits but we are doing it offline so we
take the digestate and do strong cation
exchange fractionation offline and then
run each fraction on the on the on the
mass spec the important of this slide is
to see here that we can load almost just
5 micrograms of the peptides and see how
our gradient looks like is are we happy
with the fractionation and then we do
injection analytical injection which is
represent in the blue showing each of
this fraction and we those fractions are
collected in 96 volts each fraction then
can be analyzed separately and then
after that collate collated and run
through the sequestered and any kind of
algorithm that will give you the final
protein identification so let next thing
but we are going to talk about membrane
proteins because membrane proteins are
difficult to solubilize the best thing
for to solubilize and when it we are not
talking about mass spectrometry is using
detergent but the Turgeon say
detrimental to the separation so there
are there should be some other ways how
to look into the solubalization of
membrane proteins we have used organic
solvent based system and combined with
the strong cation extraction ation and
here is the paper that we have published
a couple years ago looking into the
lipid loft of lipid rafts of cells which
are treated with iota B and with the
vehicle basically the major focus of
that study was to find out what are the
proteins that are associated at the cell
surface and internalizing I oughta be
toxin into the cell line there we have
used strong cation exchange
fractionation coupled with the lipids of
isolation using density gradients and
also we have used a 18 or 16
differential labeling to compare control
with iota be treated treated cells in
short we came out and we published a
paper with with a group of proteins that
are that are most likely differently
regulated and we have really focused on
cd44 as a potential target and markets
among the others as the one which be a
facilitator of internalization of I
oughta be talking into the into the
cells along almost 5 years after the
group the our collaborator after a lot
of molecular biology after a lot of
experiments using in vivo and
experiments they have come
our result and publish the paper that
showing that iota B is really helped or
facilitated by cd44 and then we see that
cd44 note cells are showing less of of
iota be talks in Y cd44 plus cells are
showing a lot of it so so that is one of
the examples to show how global
proteomics can be used shotgun
proteomics can be used to figure out
what are the proteins that are helping
internalization of I oughta be toxin and
then of those those proteins and so
surface can be blocked most probably the
internalization of deadly I oughta be
toxin will be mediated so here is a
paper that has been published based on
our initial study and this illustrate
the power of global quantitative
proteomics employed in discovery phase
and it was followed obviously with
cross-validation and using specific
molecular biology techniques so that was
the kind of intro into the biomarker in
drug target discovery and now I would
like to just say couple of words why do
we need biomarkers so the only biomarker
until now and the most the most of the
studies is is a famous kaplan-meier
survival curve which which shows if we
treat the animals or humans with the
some drug whether the survival is longer
so that tells us only that some drug is
effective but what the nature of that
effectiveness is is not known and the
other things these are the results which
are really collected using a multiple
subject and that would be applied to a
single subject with the for example
cancer which most likely is not going to
be
you know that it doesn't work all the
time so if we have a group of patients
with the same diagnosis and same cancer
we can see that if we just use couple
our mind curves and apply the the
treatment there are basically four
different effects that out of those four
three are not important because we we
can have that the drug is not toxic but
not beneficial that can be toxic
although beneficial cannot be used dry
can be also toxic and not beneficial
which is the worse and so drug is not
toxic and beneficial and that is
basically the only outcome that we are
interested in however if we don't share
biomarkers we don't know or we could
prevent people who might not benefit
from all patients is not in benefit from
that treatment that not going to be
enrolled in it at all so the one of the
of the major biomarkers it was the first
one is discovered is Herceptin in a
breast cancer and breast cancer is most
probably 10 years about ahead of all the
other cancers so that is an ideal
situation where immunohistochemistry is
done and we see that that the patient
tumor expresses her - and then Herceptin
can be applied if the the tumor is not
her2 positive obviously then the the
treatment is obsolete and someone should
not be exposed to unnecessary and
expensive treatment so that is basically
an intro in interceding medicine
and why what is the precision medicine
how many of definition I I prefer this
one precision or personalized medicine
emerging approach for disease threat and
treatment intervention
they takes into account individual
variability in genes environment and
lifestyle of each person and definition
what is the biomarker biomarker is
biological molecule panel of molecules
found in a blood other body fluid or
tissue that is objectively measured and
evaluated as an indica indicator of
physiological or pathological process or
response to therapeutic intervention so
one of the our major efforts in
Frederick National Laboratory for cancer
research is a Russ program which is
trying to find the way how to attack
Russ driven cancers Roz different
cancers are the biggest killers and 90%
of pancreatic cancer has mutated us
protein and about 40% of lung cancer and
colon cancer also mutate so that is an a
big initiative looking into the Roz
mutants and trying to improve the
treatment of ours even cancer our the
initiative that our group is working is
wrassle surface and then from this now I
am going to talk about our efforts in in
that arena so what we have taken into
the interred in what what our role in
the research of the in the Russ
initiative is to look at the cell
surface targets that might be different
between expressed between the Kira's
mutant cells so me in the cells or
tumors which are expressing mutants
versus those wrong which are expressing
wild-type so to address the tissue we
have basically combined two techniques
the first one is a cell surface
technology published by a basalt group
where
see sodium per yo that is used to
oxidize like lichens turn them to all
the hide and then using the hydros I
chemistry we are binding only the
peptides that are like oscillated and
washing out the peptides which are not
like oscillated so basically enriching
the cell surface of the glycosylated
proteins why did black oscillation
because 90% of cell surface proteins are
glycosylated so basically we are taking
an abyssal group has taken the advantage
of of the glycosylation pattern of the
cell surface to explore and to put it
into the context of the proteomics to
identify cell surface proteins on the on
the surface of cancer cells we combine
that with our approach that we have
developed previously we using shotgun
proteomics so we were familiar with this
slide we fractionated the the cell
surface and we should fractionated the
membrane prep and then look into the
distractions so to to cast a wide net so
we basically have two orthogonal method
like a proteomics is casting deep net
and strong cation exchange based global
membrane proteomics is casting wide net
so basically combination of those two
should that should give us the best
insight into the into the cell surface
we have published for last year and that
was the the publication which came in on
coasts where we have been we reported
our our findings first we started with
we use a model cell line which is mcs 10
a it is a breast cancer cell line why we
have used them CF 10 a cell line because
that is the only cell that is
spontaneously immortalized all other
cells which are the
immortalized they're very very close to
cancer cell line so in in this slide it
is obvious that this is mcf 10a empty
vector transfected with the empty vector
it looks like a normal act irreal cell
line with like a cobblestone and then we
have seen what is happening to the cell
line once it is translated with the
potent aquagenic chaos mutants you the
electron microscopy shows a really
transformed aggressive cells ready to
move also what we also have shown we can
see that these transferal cells are also
creating the spheres which is the really
a sign of stemness or mesenchymal and to
exterior to me the chemo transformation
also before we apply the the mass
spectrometry based proteomics we have
characterized these cell lines with the
phenotypic cancer cell assays so we have
used migration as a anchorage
independent si and invasion si all the
essays came positive showing that that
really are cells which are transfected
with Kira's are showing aggressive
behavior in terms of Anchorage
independent si and migration essays - so
this is our experimental design so what
I told you in the beginning basically we
have taken the targeted cell surface
protein omics to analyze cell surface of
these cells using like uh proteomics and
then we have used our global proteomics
strong cation exchange base and collate
the data and wanted to see what is the
difference between cell surface of cells
expressing
Kira's mutant versus empty vectors
infected infected cells
in this analysis of the like Oklahoma
Canal ADIZ we have found that 62
proteins are unique to k-rod surface 86
proteins are common and 36 are found
only on on the normal cells or empty
vectors affected cells so that was
encouraging however that was adjust the
beginning of our by automatic processing
we look down into the protein class
analysis in pathway signaling and the
interesting thing here is that in the
pathway signaling integrins signaling it
was much higher into the chaos cells and
coherent signaling has been vim
signaling all of those signaling czar
characteristic of transformed cells and
is that these signals are amplified in
transformed cells next we use ingenuity
pathways to look what are the the most
abundant networks of the proteins based
on significance statistical significance
a number of identify protein so when we
look into them glycosylated proteins the
the most amplified or most enriched
network a cellular movement cancer
cellular movement and again again
movement so all of those IP a ingenuity
pathway biological processes annotation
pointing to the cells that are ready to
move to invade or to metastasize and
then obviously we have decided and
selected the proteins for cross
validation using
Imanol fluorescence or western blot so
we have decided to look into the cdc p1
p TP rj and the other proteins and we'll
show I will show shortly how we have
validated so this is the same
representation of these networks showing
the proteins that identified
selected by ingenuity pathways those in
the purplish show that are only
identified in in on the cell surface of
the Kira's mutant cells and those in the
purple are shown that they are
upregulated in these cells so next we
have used the confocal microscopy and
showing for example that CDC p1 is very
much
located in lamellipodia of MCS nak rod
cells as MC mm - we have seen that empty
vector doesn't show that kind of the
staining and we also show this for the
pd p TP rj another network is network
which is is looking into the cancer
movement different proteins are here
buzzie gene CD 147 is important protein
cd44 and then we have shown a
edification validation of certain
targets we select the CD 147 and piero
CR and the the my microscopic imaging is
showing positive verification of the
proteomic data so we first then we next
decided to focus on CD 147 which is
bulging because we have seen bimah no
fluorescence that that protein is really
located on the cell surface of the other
cells showing in lamellipodia
particularly high expression and
lamellipodia are the part of the
organelles of the cells which make cells
moving obviously that signal is absent
in in
empty vector so what we next wanted to
know so this is this is an artificial
system that would be a really a good
critic to say okay that cell is
overflown with overexpress with MCA with
the K Raji 12e mutant so can we see what
is happening with with with the cells
that are endogenous ly expressing that
will cave as mutant so basically we look
into the lung cancer cell line which is
h2 for for one cancer cell line then we
look into the pancreatic cancer cell
line and the colon cancer cell line all
of those cell lines are expressing CD
147 and dodging ously so they are not
manipulated and even colon cancer cell
line shows spheres which are also
showing very strong signal on CD 147 so
we are excited about that and we figure
out that CD 147 can really be an
important molecules in the context of
k-rod glv mutants next week next we have
looked also into the CDC p1 so see
discipline is another protein which we
have found up regulated on the on the
cell surface of Kira's cells and when we
used the very high resolution microscopy
we can see that these proteins even
co-localize on the cell surface of the
holder of the cells and trying to see is
there any link between those two two
proteins we further moved and look into
the together with the acting and we have
found out that CD 147 and CDC p1 are
actually organized along the actin
filaments in the membrane making that
kind of
the complex complex very important for
the biology of mcf DNA cells transfected
or infected with Kayla's jewelry
we also found an interest we also have
found an interesting feature of the MCF
DNA k-rod detail via cells when we see
that the acting is really mobilized to
the cell surface rather rather than to
the is then just polymerized inside the
cells so that is another interesting
finding in conjunction with the
redistribution of the actin filaments in
the transformed cells then we looked
into the those are the data that we got
with the glycoprotein mix next we look
into the data which we go through the
global proteomics and the first of the
network and reached there was embryonic
development and we don't know very well
that cancer cells and during the
tumorigenesis vary a lot of embryonic
programs get hijacked and activated well
shouldn't be really in in the matured
cells so we have found that our next
receptor has been up regulated into the
corral jewelry cells and when we look in
the upstream analysis regulator effect
analysis we found out that proteins that
we identified are very much linked to
the Kira's glv biology also we found
that the regulatory effect is one of the
major regulator of of this
transformation is tgf-beta
so when we combine all all the data from
both of the of the analysis using
Global's membrane photonics and
glycoprotein mix we find out that 300
proteins are unique to the K Raji for
speed digital resurface and this is out
of a 1,300 protein that we have
identified so basically we are able to
make a map of the proteins to mark the
cell surface of Kayla's jewelry cell
line and punter classification like for
the glycoprotein mix has given us a
better insight into the into the pathway
amplification in this cell line and
after that we did the same exercise we
look into the cell surface proteins how
they are what are the the most abundant
or most activated protein networks are
so looking with the global membrane
proteomics cellular movement and cancer
I again jog metabolism a solar movement
invasion and formation of cellular
protrusions which is really important
because we have seen those protrusions
on the owner in well in transformed in
transform cells here are the proteins
that we were able to cross validate
using immunofluorescence caring for
Vangel and Sheila's are very much
expressed on the cell surface of
transformed cancer cell line besides ABC
a tooth COC 97 and XP are running TG b
r2 also up next we have found also that
the coverage of the rats pathway was
really remarkable shedding and also we
have seen we have also been able to
identify
a higher expression of such 2k rosin
rosin a trois which is an interesting
thing and bar soggy group has shown
before that
Kiera's is not the only protein that
drives the tumorigenesis that an age has
also are mutated are important for
transformation of this cell so what we
have done we have basically defined and
non redundant surface map of K residual
V cells and we have used both cell
surface technology and global membrane
proteomics so this analysis revealed the
complement of 500 non-redundant surface
protein species detected and uniquely we
found 30 hundred 300 proteins found only
on on the cell surface of chaos data we
transform ourselves and 195 proteins
that are regulated out of 308
non-redundant protein species identified
solely or the k vegeto surface 177 55%
57 percent we authentic lycra proteins
cataloged by cell surface protein atlas
the reminder of 131 proteins were
annotated by ingenuity pathway pathway
databases genuine cell surface proteins
so basically what that is a really a
benefit of using both of those because
we are seeing glycoproteins and non
glycosylated protein at the cell surface
amongst 195 195 normally under cell
surface proteins we have found that a
total of 89
we are cell surface proteins cataloged
by the cell surface protein atlas so and
then reminding 106 molecules we
annotated the down tentacle surface
protein so basically we see that the
verify percentage of membrane protein
so surface 14 identified their one
important thing is also that
concomitantly with us
the Japanese group has used images of
chemistry no mass spectrometry and they
have looked into the human tumor tissues
using immunohistochemistry and they have
found that CD 147 and cdc p1 are the
proteins that they believe are important
as a marker of lung cancers which is
driven with bit Kira's mutants so from
the many aspects we have shown that that
approach is definitely something that
can be used as an accessory tool in any
clinical research so here I was going to
end up with my presentation I would like
to acknowledge scientists which are
working with me the separation the
separation is done by dr. Chang
showering she's the one who did all the
experiments and data analysis and the
roof has helped us a lot with with the
sample preparation and I would like also
to acknowledge the last initiative
leadership which is of Frank McCormack
lightness lightness Lee and Gordon white
Lee we have also our collaborators from
UCLA NCI and with that I'm going to
finish my presentation and I'm ready to
take any questions if they are available
well thank you dr. blonder for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on the screen and click on the send
button will answer as many questions as
we have time for so let's get started
with our first question of the day
dr. blonder the first question asks what
is LC and ass so that's a good question
liquid chromatography mass spectrometry
so that is a basically a simple thing
for people who are not put mass
spectrometry geeks that means that mass
spectrometers are coupled with the
liquid chromatography is powerful tool
for the analysis of complex biological
samples samples and that is also an
antibody free technique excellent thank
you for that information the next
question asks what is the what is
Hyderabad based glycoprotein X so the
high design based proteomics is an
approach that relies really on the
oxidation of glycans turning them into
all the hides and then covalently
binding them to the high design that
allows us to wash out everything that is
not covalently bound and then we use PNG
and AF to release the peptides which are
glycosylated that is a very powerful
technique in looking into the life of
proteomics we're using like of Atomics
to look into the cell surface protein
thank you dr. blonder let's see our next
question reads why is the cell surface
protein important and drug discovery
process so the major thing that is
already everyone most probably know that
but I would like to reiterate that that
the most of the contemporary drug
targets are targeting so surface 70% of
all drugs which are targeting which are
used in the pharmaceutical
pharmaceutical treatment of the any kind
of disease targets of surface proteins
and there are two reason why they are
important first
accessibility because they're on the
cell surface they don't need to be the
molecules that targeting them don't need
to be internalized number one and number
two these proteins are basically the
molecules that help cells to sense the
outer world
so basically accessibility and then it
can be shut down not only the molecules
that cells is sending its environment
but also the molecules that are helping
cells in taking the metabolites food and
anything important for survival
thank you so much for that answer
so we are running tight on time so this
will be the last question of the webinar
this question asks what is the
difference between lc/ms based
proteomics in imaging mass spectometry
so both of these techniques are using
mass spectrometry as a detector lc/ms
base doesn't need antibodies because
nowadays we do know that it is very
difficult to find a set of good
characterized antibodies in a context of
lc/ms based proteomics antibodies are
not needed imaging cytometry is very
important but that can be only applied
for the subsets of all of some of in
advance i advanced no targets so lc/ms
is really the prime tool for discovery
and the other one is most probably for
cross-validation they are both very
needed and very important but one need
to know distinction between two of those
absolute thank you so much for that
answer I would like to thank you once
again dr. blonder for your presentation
I'd also like to thank lappers for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
during January 12th of 20
18 you will receive an email from lab
roots wedding you know when this webcast
will be available for replay please
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon here at lab roots
goodbye